what makes field trust different from
other companies is that people my
teammates have the absolute best heart
and intention everyone genuinely cares
about the team and constantly want to
produce the best work possible honestly
scaling and
growing with people who are aligned who
are eager to contribute makes work super
fun and meaningful as far as my personal
life
i don't have one
next question working at filters means
that i am constantly challenged to put
out the best work that i can and this
has challenged me to become the best
version of myself outside of work i seek
personal improvement whenever i can and
i've learned to step out of my comfort
zone and do something that makes me a
little uncomfortable for instance i am
currently training for four marathon
with my co-worker this is something i
would never have done on my own i
empower people by encouraging them to
bring funders myself to work i want
people to take ownership of their
accomplishments as well as failures what
makes filtrus a fun place to work the
mission the people and the opportunity
to whip up a storm in this industry i
try to create a thriving environment
where diversity is understood and
accepted and collaboration with other
departments is as easy as walking down
the stairs and chatting with someone i
enjoy working here because of the people
we have a very collaborative and
transparent culture i stayed because i
enjoy working with the people
i don't have a life
okay okay
my teammates have absolute of the ops
i empower my teammates by giving them
ice cream
all right
what makes filtrus a fun place to work
is that it oh yeah oh yeah oh that's it